newly-released body camera video gives a
dramatic new view from one of the two
police officers who shot at a car near
Yale University in Connecticut the
footage shows the officer firing several
shots at the car last week a woman in
the passenger seat was injured she and
the driver did not appear to be armed
both officers involved in the shooting
are on administrative leave while an
investigation tries to determine if they
were justified in opening fire Molo
Lengai is in new New Haven Connecticut
mall oh good morning oh good morning
John the shooting happened right here at
this intersection just one week ago
officials acknowledge that it's unusual
for body cam video to be released after
just one week it's a process that
typically takes four to six months but
with increasing pressure officials chose
to be more transparent investigators say
handin police officer Devin Eden
initially failed to turn on his body
camera but the footage his camera did
capture shows Eaton take aim at a car
with a driver and passenger inside 22
year old Stephanie Washington was the
passenger she was shot in the face the
driver 21 year old Paul Witherspoon was
somehow uninjured he got out of the car
an instant before the first shots were
fired
the Connecticut public safety
commissioner James Ravello there are
indications that he was told to open the
door yes or come out with his hands up
which is what he appears it looks like
it but I can't tell you what's in one of
the hands Witherspoon's red car matched
the description of one reported in an
alleged armed robbery surveillance video
shows Eaton shuffled by the car while
shooting through the rear and side
windows
Yale University officer Terrence [ __ ]
who also shot at the vehicle was hit by
bullet fragments he failed to turn on
his body and dash cameras all together
which state officials say is
inconsistent with state statutes and
policies we need to really look at like
what's really going on with the police
and how they look at people in our city
like in all the cities Withers
uncle Rodney Williams stressed to police
the need to repair trust with the
community following a week of peaceful
protests in which the community demanded
accountability when something happen
come together as one and that's how you
make a difference Keisha Greene is
Witherspoon's mother she says the
officers alleged actions are inexcusable
I understand that you have a job to do
and you want to go home to your family
but the people that you're pulling over
we want to go home to ours too
the public safety commissioner says that
Witherspoon and Washington are not
facing charges meanwhile Stephanie
Washington is expected to make a full
physical recovery Nora that is good news
emphasis on the word physical there
mm-hmm the police officers in that case
have a lot of explaining to do what if
they came up with something guys at the
minute you pull out your gun your your
camera is activated then you don't have
the option of turning it off or turning
it off the technology is such somebody
ought to be able to figure out a way to
do that because it defeats the whole
purpose if you have a body cam and you
don't turn it on it helps with
accountability exactly